today's topic flag reacts now last week
we covered a video on flat reacts
involving him during a live stream
having a
huge altercation with his uh
ex-girlfriend at the time
uh basically she wanted to get back
together make it work he said now we're
done
you're over with then she started making
a big scene police officers were
involved
and it was all caught on live stream so
everyone's kind of happy for flight
finally standing up for himself he seems
to have a bad streak with some
girlfriends and some baby mamas
and so we're all kind of glad that he's
finally moving on less than six days
later he puts out a video saying that
he's
back with the very same woman
who reclaimed he would never get back
with i'm the king here i'm the king here
you learn to act right
you're insecure
i'm not deleting [ __ ] you learn how to
act right you talk you talking
are you talking to right now look at
this right now look who you're talking
to bro and i'm not opening the [ __ ]
door bro
no just go home i'll give you a [ __ ] the
other day i'll pull up on you with me
halfway somewhere you're not coming in
today just going
who's knocking like that i am
the one who knocks it and i'm not
opening the [ __ ] door
bro you're crazy you're wasting your
time
i'm not going for it delete the tweet
i'm not ending the stream bro i'm gonna
give you like five ten minutes for
i'm gonna mute it let me finish
streaming i'll be off in like an hour
and a half two hours we can talk after
what are you doing fatality
ain't no other dude is going except you
having the only fans
every female is getting five to ten day
contrast you have one week
are me and andrea back together yes you
have one week if you're lucky
two weeks you know i'm saying to enjoy
your time with that reacts and you're
gone
that girl is my fiance i'm a married a
shout at her one day i'm just too bossed
up and too much of a king to be giving
no girl a relationship or you know what
i'm saying dealing with no female bro i
just want to let you know andre
you're my baby and i love the dog [ __ ]
out of you yes
she kept repeating saying that like oh
like i've never acted like this like
you're the best guy that's ever came
into my life
like cool you still fumble the bag i
don't give a [ __ ] about your sob stories
bro yes
we're working [ __ ] out you know what i'm
saying what are you gonna do about it
i'm single bro um single
saying you're 100 single i'm gonna be
safe yo you know what i'm saying like
trust me i'm not stupid
i'm gonna give her like three to four
kids three to four
kids i'm not stupid
you're my baby you ain't going nowhere
you're stuck with me i'm not gonna let
nobody like change my decision on
somebody just because of one bad moment
everybody has bad moments
and honestly you guys there's so much
other [ __ ] that she's dead and
so much of the tea as soon as you feel
like your emotions is off tacking
out of you know what i'm saying sync bro
drop that [ __ ] bro you know what i'm
saying
andre it makes me happy um like i said
it's the last time being in a
relationship
if you guys see me with like a girl or
anything just know they own a five to
ten day contract
stand
[Laughter]
man if you like this edit if you thought
this edit was dope
put a like leave a comment help us out
with the algorithm i put mad work into
it
at the end of the day none of us cheated
on each other andre never cheated on me
my loyalty is gonna really honestly
remain high with somebody that has never
cheated on me like no matter what
anybody has to say
throughout all that [ __ ] andrea
makes me happy
that girl is my fiance i'm gonna marry
the shot of her one day
andrea baby girl i love you i'm not
being held hostage by the way everybody
nobody's in the crib i promise y'all
you know what i'm saying that was
another thing too you know what i'm
saying just because i say
somebody left me hostage does not mean
that she had a [ __ ]
ak to my head bro for five hours bro it
basically just means that she just
wouldn't leave you know what i'm saying
because she wanted to
work things out you know i'm saying i
finally got her out you know what i'm
saying we had
those couple of days or you know what
i'm saying almost a week of
you know i'm saying thank you [ __ ] out
and having a break we don't choose to
work [ __ ] out you know what i'm saying
now look
uh at the end of the day we all have the
right to make whatever choices we want
to be with whoever we want to be
i think in this case i think fleischer's
being a bit of a hypocrite you know
he's giving advice to folks that he
himself is not following
literally five six days apart so i think
it's okay to call him out on it but you
know at the end it's his life
if he wants to be involved with her and
that's what he loves and hey man all the
power to you
i don't want to spend too much time on
this topic so i don't think it deserves
nearly as much attention as people think
it does
the other day this is man's life if he
likes giant drama filled circles that's
fine like i said
when it comes to these kind of
relationships and these kinds of
you know violations of boundaries you
know it's on the individual for allowing
someone in their life
to continuously do this stuff to them a
lot of the times and it seems like
that's the same case for
flight so if this is the life that he
chooses that's on him
you know i'm not here trying to save
people from themselves also this week
we're going to be doing a lot of videos
on all kinds of topics everything from
super straight to
uh sweetie to cuevo to um
to little nas x all these things so if
you want to get early access to these
videos
head over to the patreon right now get
access a lot of videos plus bonus
content
can be found there
[Laughter]
just imagine me with some dreads it's
the same thing